the Austrian World Summit on climate
action is underway in Vienna organizers
are urging world leaders to stick to the
agreements outlined in the Paris Accord
and publish new commitments by next year
it is the brainchild of former
California Governor Arnold
Schwarzenegger also in attendance is
Swedish climate activists Greta Toon
Burke she's inspired tens of thousands
of young people around the world with
her Fridays for future school strike now
in her speech she had a stark message
for the audience have a lesson during
the last month's millions of children
have been school striking for the
climate gaining lots of attention for
the climate crisis but we children are
not leaders nor are the scientists
unfortunately but many of you here today
are presidents celebrities politicians
CEOs and journalists people listen to
you they are influenced by you and
therefore you have an enormous
responsibility and let's be honest this
is a responsibility that most of you
have failed to take on now about that
enormous responsibility I'm joined by my
colleague objet niranjan from our
environment desk I mean you really see
it there a call for action as we've
heard from her time and time again how
high is the hope for that action right
now I think hope is really high and
increasingly it's growing we've seen
particularly in Europe for instance on
the back of these European elections
where green parties saw a huge surge
across the continent and with things
like Greta tune both Fridays for future
movement and for instance in the UK this
extinction rebellion protests where
they've shut down roads I think people
are really starting to recognize the
importance of climate change in their
daily lives and I started to demand more
from governments and officials to
actually do something about it
reducing carbon emissions what else
needs to be done so much more else needs
to be done but it's very hard to talk
about these concretely without sort of
underst
how interlinked all these different
processes are so one of the big issues
and this maybe not such focus of the
conference is things like saving
biodiversity and sort of damage we're
doing to nature but one of the problems
I think a lot of the activists find I
love the scientists find is that because
these issues are so interlinked but
they're also quite abstract it's very
difficult for people to really engage
with them and that's why one of the
focuses of the conference which I
thought was really interesting is about
climate communication and how to get
people to care about how to get people
to take action on it and I think that's
one thing we see with figures like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and Greta tune
Berg who I mean they come from
completely different backgrounds they've
got this or a 71 year old action star
bodybuilder and a 16 year old school
girl you've both had extreme impacts all
over the world with really being able to
communicate a message around climate
that scientists say they're struggling
to get across so and I think as a focus
that definitely give them more room to
be able to actually engage with people
and get them to go through those may be
more dense solutions around say green
financing or divestment from fossil
fuels and so on I don't know and John
from our environment desk thank you
thank you